we will be seeing the titans and the
steelers play this week the game is
postponed it is proceeding it's because
of the covet 19 outbreak at the
tennessee titans facility and within the
team four players are positive five
staff members are positive facility
closed until
saturday
and
it's going forward so uh that's good
news now do we have shireen a final
decision i've been out of the loop for
the last hour or so is there a final
decision as to when the game is actually
happening
now they're hoping to play it on monday
but who knows if we're going to have
more positive tests or how this thing is
going to play out and if it does play on
tuesday mike
trivia question for you do you know the
last time the nfl played a two stay game
and there's a reason i'm asking you this
question yes yes it was december 28 2010
it was the vikings at the eagles it was
joe webb beating mike vick 24-14
we were there and i don't i i don't know
that i have a ticket stub because i was
there with nbc actually what we did that
game was supposed to be a sunday night
game and we were in studio when the
blizzard was bearing down on new york
philadelphia and the east coast
and uh they just
moved the game to tuesday night so we
stayed in the city and went down to
philadelphia by train and did the game
from there on tuesday night down on the
field pre-game post game halftime and uh
yeah joe webb somehow beat uh mike vick
because brett favre that may have been
like the first start he had ever missed
once his streak began because he had a
concussion i believe but uh yeah
december 28 2010 it makes for a short
week on the back end i hope it's not
tuesday because then the titans have
five days to play the bills and the
steelers have five days to get ready for
their next game i think against the
browns i'd almost rather if they move to
tuesday
the bills game the following week and
the steelers game the following week be
moved to monday and see when you don't
have fans you can you can you're
flexible right you can move a game from
sunday to monday sunday to tuesday
whenever you can do that and i hope that
they don't put the bills and the
steelers in a position by moving into
tuesday
where they'd be pinched to get ready for
the games that they have the following
sunday
and you know mike we've talked about
this a lot but the league has built in
all these
areas where they can move games and
change games if you notice on the
schedule this week there are no
divisional match-ups and that was
intended because if they had a covet
outbreak this week those games could be
thrown away or put at the end of the
year or whatever but they were not
divisional match-ups
so they could do away with them so
they've planned all these things out now
we know what happens to the best late
plans sometimes they don't work out but
they have built this in different
various things and so they're hoping to
get this one in and then we'll be four
weeks in without having a game at least
canceled we will have had it postponed
but not canceled and more is coming i
mean we know that this in league knows
that this is not a surprise and it's not
going to be a surprise going forward
when we have more of these types of
situations
well it's definitely going to keep
coming if teams like the raiders have
their starting quarterback and multiple
other members of the team showing up at
events that violate local ordinances
regarding indoor activities people
without masks on
and they were concerned that that kind
of stuff would happen later in the year
when teams are essentially eliminated
from playoff contention not in september
when everyone's still alive and they
were concerned about guys at the bottom
of the roster young guys guys that would
do stupid things that would give in to
youthful indiscretions not the starting
quarterback of the team who should know
better so the raiders haven't announced
whether or not they're doing anything
about those players they have the power
to implement discipline the problem is
if they start disciplining guys their
starting quarterback is going to be
caught in that same vice and that is a
major problem and i'm not suggesting
they're going to suspend anybody but
they have to do something otherwise it
sends a horrible message to everyone
else in the locker room and the rest of
the league that there aren't real
consequences for this kind of behavior
which really is even more shocking than
the titans outbreak because we knew it
was inevitable there was going to be an
outbreak i didn't believe it would be
inevitable that would we'd see a scene
like that just a few weeks into the
season where stupidity overcomes the
the common sense and the logistics and
the protocols aimed at limiting the
spread of the virus and the thing about
the uh titan steelers game
real quickly
if it does happen monday or tuesday that
will mean
i believe that we don't have any more
positives we don't have a further
outbreak because i think the delay to
monday or tuesday is all about giving
the titans some fair opportunity to
prepare for the game by having a couple
of practices but enough from us let's
hear from the two head coaches who will
be squaring off hopefully on monday or
tuesday mike frable and mike tomlin of
the titans and the steelers
you know i know there's going to be a
lot of questions
about the game and about who's to blame
and where it started
um
nobody's to blame
you know
we're in a pandemic
unfortunately things happen john and i
feel comfortable that since
receiving the protocols in august we
followed those
um
by the letter
and that we were conscious of everything
that we did this is a very unfortunate
situation
but one that we're
confident that we will be able to handle
safely
with the football team and the players
best interest in mind
no mental issues for us um regardless of
all the variables that you mentioned it
was a wednesday for us we had a base
preparation day regardless of those
circumstances and so we've tried to uh
stay focused on that and to be honest
with you this cove environment would
close locker rooms and so forth has
really provided us an opportunity to do
that probably easier than normal
circumstances
now i want to go back to what mike rabel
said sharim the
notion that there's no one to blame i
don't know that i buy that because
and i love mike vrabel but
the ultimate pass fail is whether or not
you keep the virus out of your facility
someone when you have all of these
protocols in the daily testing and the
six feet and the contact tracers and the
bracelets that vibrate if you get too
close to somebody and the wearing of the
masks and everything they're putting in
place
someone
either failed to design the right
protocol because the protocols are
supposedly designed to keep the virus
out or someone failed in the actual
following of the protocol uh the virus
wins
and the question is whether or not this
game is going to get scrapped and
whether or not they can get it played
and whether or not the facility is going
to continue to be shut down but
somewhere somehow
there there is blame to be late we may
never know
but if everything worked the way it was
supposed to this wouldn't have happened
or maybe there's an issue with the
protocols and if that's the problem then
they better fix them because you got 31
other teams that could end up in the
same spot
well everybody right now mike is
pointing to shane bowen and obviously he
didn't make the trip he tested positive
saturday morning he's the outside
linebacker's coach and the defensive
play caller for the titans and so he
test positive he doesn't make the trip
we assume he tested positive we don't
know that for sure he went into covet
protocol and didn't make the trip so
we're assuming now that he did test
positive for it and it was not a false
negative uh a false positive and so here
we sit now with the locker room i don't
want to say breakout but it is a
breakout i guess technically counting
the other personnel besides the players
who have tested positive so everybody's
pointing the finger at shane bowen
saying all right you brought this in
we don't know that and we don't know how
it started but they do need to figure
out
where it started how it was brought in
who has it all those things or if the
protocols are working if they need to do
something else in that facility uh to
make it better because they're the first
team obviously to have this happen
during the season so they need to figure
it out
the vikings are so effective because the
titans played minnesota on sunday the
vikings clearly have no blame they just
happen to play the titans the vikings
are optimistic they can reopen their
facility on thursday and the good news
is to the extent that anyone was
positive on the field for the titans on
sunday the idea that the virus won't
spread during games because of the open
air or the high ceiling with the great
ventilation with the droplets
dissipating quickly so infections can't
spread among opponents that's good news
if we can even read that you know into
what happened between the vikings and
the titans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports